from hand hygiene and Dawn and gloves
take the antiseptic swab and clean along
the wound to grasp the knot with our
tweezers cut that part of the thread
lift up and pull over the wound make
sure it's intact drop it into your gauze
grab the knot snip underneath it lift up
and then pull over the wound and drop in
the glass take a new antiseptic swab and
clean the areas where you remove the
suture whenever you're applying steri
strips you want to gently lay down one
part of it smooth it down and then
gently lay down the other side don't
pull it to create tension smooth it down
and then gently other side grab your
knot cut underneath pull up and over
facing the gauze underneath and lift up
and pull over and drop it in the gauze
grab the knot cut underneath lift up a
little bit and then pull over make a new
antiseptic swab clean those areas
three-fourths inch on each side of the
incision about 1 8 inch apart